CHARLIE HARDING: All right,
thanks everyone for coming.
I'm Charlie Harding.
I'm a partnerships
manager at google.org.
And it's my pleasure to
introduce Beverly Schwartz.
Beverly is the
author of "Rippling:
How Social Entrepreneurs
Spread Innovation
Throughout the World."
And she is also
the vice president
of global marketing for
Ashoka, where she currently
leads a program and a
partnership with The MasterCard
Foundation to help fund
innovative solutions
to youth empowerment in Africa.
It's really exciting to host
Bev and Ashoka at Google,
because we've had a
long-standing relationship
with Ashoka.
Ashoka, if you don't
know, was founded in 1980,
and they support about 3,000
leading social entrepreneurs
around the world and have
the mission to make everybody
a changemaker.
Google supported Ashoka
in 2010 with a $1 million
grant to help support their
News & Knowledge programs.
And Googlers today can
continue to volunteer
on a part-time basis through
the GooglersGive program.
So you can go to GooglersGive,
and you can actually
volunteer your time
to work with Ashoka.
So I believe there's
a dozen programs
or so that we've helped work
on through GooglersGive.
As a bit more background on
Bev, by discipline, Beverly
is an entrepreneurial
behavioral scientist
and has made her career in
the field of social change
marketing over
the past 30 years.
She has a background in
advertising and communications
and has an extensive career
in marketing, especially
in the field of social change,
working in private, nonprofit,
and public sectors on
issues from drug prevention
and smoking prevention to
gender equity and education.
About the book, "Rippling"
is described as a blueprint
for visionary thinking about how
to tackle the world's biggest
social and environmental
challenges.
She draws on examples
of empathy, innovation,
creativity, passion,
and persistence
to make real change in the
world and pulls case studies
from Ashoka Fellows to
exemplify these characteristics.
"Rippling" has won
two big awards,
including the 2013 Nautilus
Award and the 2013 "Inc.
Magazine"-sponsored Axiom
Business Book Award.
Thank you all for joining
us this afternoon.
I would like to have you join me
in welcoming Bev to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: So I'll
hand-hold this right?
OK, great.
Thanks, Charlie.
I really appreciate it.
First, I really want to
thank you for coming,
but also Kat Welch, who
is a Google volunteer that
has chosen Ashoka as her
organization of choice.
And she actually suggested
this and put this whole thing
together.
And if anybody's
interested afterward,
Radhika Shah is here.
And she is starting an Ashoka
chapter in Silicon Valley
so that we sort of can
have people connected
to us right here where you live.
CHARLIE HARDING: Bev, I
forgot to plug your book.
It's available outside.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Oh, yeah.
Thank you, Charlie.
That was my hand.
And if you're interested,
and if you are inspired,
and you have one extra
second a week to read,
because I know they work
you pretty hard here,
the book is outside.
Actually, I have to say,
I'm a little bit in awe
of being here, not because
it's a well-known place
but because you actually
live very close to the Ashoka
vision.
And Charlie was kind enough
to take me on a tour today.
And I realized as we
were walking around
that your culture is really
what needs to happen--
and I will expound on
that a little later--
in the rest of the world.
But what I wanted
to do today was
talk about, not so much
innovation entrepreneurs,
which I think you
live and breathe,
but another type
of entrepreneur,
which is a social entrepreneur.
I also find it
interesting that, out
of all of the audiences
that I've spoken to,
you actually understand
what entrepreneurship is.
And so that sort of makes
this a much easier talk.
And so you actually
get it from the get go.
So today I just wanted to talk
a bit about what the differences
are between a
business or, what I'm
going to call
today, an innovation
entrepreneur, and a
social entrepreneur.
And I want to give
you sort of the touch
and the feel and the essence.
It sort of sounds like
that cotton advertisement
on TV, the touch
and feel of cotton.
But I really want to give
you some concrete examples
of what they do in the
world and why what they do
is as important as it is.
And then I want to
tell you a little bit
about why I wrote the book.
And as Charlie said, I'm
a behavioral scientist
by discipline.
And that means
that I investigate
human behavior and the
dynamics of groups.
I'm rather fascinated by it.
And I always want
to understand why
there are some people in this
world that can take what is
and what if and turn
it into what can be.
And I try to see, well, how
do we replicate these people,
how do we clone these people?
You might have been able
to tell from my accent,
I am from New York, born
and bred in New York City.
And I'm slowing down
my speech on purpose.
But remember, because
I'm from New York,
I have extreme license to
mispronounce anything I want.
So if I mispronounce
it, go with me.
So many years ago, there was
a citizen protection group,
unarmed, that started in 1978,
called the Guardian Angels.
Does anybody remember what
a Guardian Angel-- Thanks,
people around my age here.
And I'm actually sad
that you don't know.
It was a group.
And they wore red
berets and red jackets.
And they started to patrol the
New York City subway system,
because they felt that
it was getting dangerous
and people were
unprotected there.
There weren't enough police.
And they decided as a citizens
group to do something about it.
They have now spread to 15
countries and 144 cities
in the world.
And they started in the
New York City subways.
I was fascinated by
this as a young girl,
because who were these people
that went out of the box?
They stood out from the norm.
They actually did something
about subway violence
that nobody else
was willing to do.
And with that example, now you
sort of know what fascinates me
and what makes me tick.
So that when I found out
about Ashoka, I thought,
wow, here are people
that go out of the norm.
Here are people that do
something for others.
They totally change their
life from what they know,
and they do something
completely different.
Many times they give up a
profession, a fair amount
of money, because
there's something
that makes them
tick differently.
And now you know
part of why I wrote
"Rippling" was because I
needed to analyze that.
I needed to research it.
I needed to understand that.
So another thing about
Ashoka that you should know,
because it'll come up
later, is I describe Ashoka
as a mini MacArthur
grant to people.
So we find the leading
people around the world
doing things in
social innovation.
They're doing something
totally different
in a country that
ever was there before.
Case in point and not in
the book, a woman in Egypt
who has started the home
health care business.
Now, you know, no
big deal, right?
We have it here.
But in Egypt, you don't
allow a non-related woman
into your house to
take care of you.
So to change the whole system
of elderly care in Egypt
was a huge deal, and we felt
it was a big enough innovation
to elect her as
an Ashoka Fellow.
And what we do with
an Ashoka Fellow is
we give them three years
of a living wage stipend
so that they can
say, wow, I don't
have to worry about
feeding my kids,
I don't have to worry
about paying my house rent.
I could actually turn my
attention to my innovation
and build my organization.
So we have now 3,000,
maybe a little more,
of these people around
the world, all of which
have gone through this
three-year period of building
their organizations
and growing it.
So by the time the
stipend is over,
they're kind of on their
way into an established
and a sustainable
idea and organization.
So what makes people tick?
Why do people stand
out from the norm?
This is something that
I've looked at now--
and I have interviewed
about 150 Fellows--
and came down to 18
of them in the book.
And I'll explain some
of that and the criteria
for it a little bit later.
But a picture like this may
not be abnormal to you--
which, by the way, you realize
that everybody in this room
is really not
normal, because you
live in a bit of an
abnormal world, not so much
as Google, not so much
in Silicon Valley,
but-- because I lived here
in California for 10 years,
I can say this-- you live in
one of the more progressive--
probably, let's face it,
the most progressive state
in the country.
And you have a whole
different culture
and a whole different idea.
I mean, even today
we were at lunch,
and it took me
about five minutes
to figure out where
I put my food bowls,
in compost and here and there.
I mean, it's very different.
And so a picture like this
wouldn't be a big deal for you.
But, do you know, I've
shown this picture before
at different speeches,
and it actually
makes people downright
uncomfortable
to be out of the norm.
But that upside-down
person is exactly what
a social entrepreneur is.
Does anybody here
know who coined
the phrase "entrepreneur?"
OK, it was one of
our French neighbors,
in 1800, Jean-Baptiste
Say, who was
a French businessmen
and economist, coined
the phrase "entrepreneur."
And he said, it's someone who
shifts an economic resource
from an area of lower to higher
productivity with greater
yield.
And the only difference between
an innovation entrepreneur
and a social entrepreneur is a
different resource being used
and a different
outcome on the yield.
And 100 years later, another
economist, who, by the way,
was not French but an
Austrian-American, Joseph
Schumpeter added something to
the definition which I think
is very important.
He said, an entrepreneur
is the source
of creative destruction
essential to the economy.
That one I like a lot, because
when you're an innovation
entrepreneur and a
social entrepreneur,
you're a disrupter.
And we are all disrupters.
Somebody reminded me that a
lot of what you work in here
is around product
entrepreneurship
and around a service
surrounding a product.
What you don't work in is
a change in human systems
development, right?
So that's the big deal
between these two ends.
What we're disrupting is
human system development
for the betterment of society.
But again, you've got
to disrupt in order
to recreate and rebuild.
So keep it in mind
that you're all
disrupters, right
here, right now.
So let's have a little fun with
this and go into a brain scan.
And this is a phrenology model.
And I don't know if
you're familiar with it,
but it shows personality
and characteristics--
and this is a mouthful--
of the proportion
of a person's propensities.
In other words, it
looks at what proportion
do your character and
your personality have
and where they are in the brain.
So I did not create this.
Because frankly, I'm not good
enough to do this on a graphic
or on a PowerPoint.
But I loved it when I saw it.
And it has nine centers.
And can you read it?
Everybody can read this?
Look how small
the trust area is.
Now this, again, is an
entrepreneur, an innovation
entrepreneur and not
a social entrepreneur.
There's going to be a
big difference coming up.
The trust area is small, because
around product development
there is an issue
called competition.
And you really don't want
to trust a lot of people
and tell them your idea, because
somebody will swoop right
in and create it before
you've got it on the market.
Also be aware of this very
small area called patience.
Does that remind you
of anybody you know?
AUDIENCE: Uh, huh.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Uh, huh.
And so an entrepreneur, an
innovation entrepreneur,
because of this whole
competitive bubble,
also has very little patience.
They need to get their idea out.
They need to implement it.
And there is really not a lot
of time that they want to waste,
OK?
But all of them, all of
the entrepreneurs I know,
both social and innovation,
espouse to my favorite Marcel
Proust quote, another
Frenchman, who
said, "the real
voyage of discovery
is not in seeking
new landscapes,
but it's in seeing
with new eyes."
So therefore, every
entrepreneur sees
something slightly different
that no one else has
seen before, and that's
called their innovation.
But here's where we start to
diverge from an innovation
entrepreneur to a
social entrepreneur.
Because the social entrepreneurs
come from all walks of life,
really phenomenal.
And they start out
someplace where they never
thought they'd end up.
So in the book, I
have a truck driver.
I have a veterinary surgeon who
now builds rickshaws in India--
here is where I
go from New York--
AUDIENCE: Ergonomics.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ:
--ergonomics, thank you,
ergonomic rickshaws--
and has a whole system
around making a rickshaw
driver feel more
like a part of society,
have health insurance,
have accident insurance.
And if you ever have been
in a rickshaw in India,
that's quite an accomplishment.
But he was a veterinary surgeon.
I've got a PhD
biomedical engineer.
I've got another
engineer who grew up
in the jungles of the Amazon.
I've got somebody so
self-labeled as a housewife.
So they started here.
And something happened
on their path.
What happened?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Nothing.
Just go on.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: I
didn't do it, right?
FEMALE SPEAKER: No.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: OK, thank you.
Something happened on their
path that absolutely changed
the trajectory of their lives.
OK, maybe it was this slide.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ:
So one of the things
that really separates a
social entrepreneur is
their proclivity
towards empathy,
sharing and understanding
the feelings of others.
And in every single person
I interviewed for the book,
this was one of the
things that really hit me.
They really felt the
pain of other people.
And I was pretty
shocked by that.
That comes to play
a little bit later.
So let's look about
the phrenology
of a social entrepreneur and
how it's a little different.
And of course, this
one I added in.
Look at the trust area.
It grows all the way, because
social entrepreneurs actually
don't have competition in mind.
And actually what they do
is they almost open source
their innovation
to actually have
it improved by other people.
We do this all the time
with Ashoka Fellows.
We put them together from
different disciplines
in a room to hash out ideas.
And everybody loves
everybody else's ideas.
And all they have to do
is try to improve them.
And nobody seems to have
a problem with that.
Then look at things like
the degree of empathy.
And they dream about a
more equitable society.
Not that innovation
entrepreneurs don't, but it's
not their primary motivation.
In a social entrepreneur,
the primary motivation
comes first, the
innovation second.
It's a little bit different
in an innovation entrepreneur.
They think in systems change.
And I'm going to demonstrate
that in a little bit.
And they're willing to invest
in human capacity and value
because they do
believe that everyone
but everyone, no
exception, had the ability
to change their
lives for the better.
So one of the
visions of Ashoka is
that everybody has the
power to be a changemaker
and that you have the
ability, with a little help,
to change your lives.
And if you are a
changemaker, you
are empowered to
change your life.
So a little vignette
here about me.
I don't think I ever
would have written
my book without having
worked at Ashoka.
And at the time
I wrote the book,
it was a little over six
years that I was there.
Because we really walk the talk.
As we talk about the rest
of the world changing,
Ashoka doesn't hire
people that they
don't think are changemakers.
And then you are
encouraged, in fact, it's
more than encouraged--
and I have
a feeling this is a bit like
Google-- you are expected
to make change within Ashoka.
Now, this drives me a
little chaotic sometimes,
a little bazoo, because as
the global marketing director,
marketing does
have sort of rules
that we call branding and
other rules like that,
that if you're an entrepreneur
at Ashoka, a changemaker,
the rules don't mean
a whole lot there.
You're always recreating a rule.
You're always
recreating a system.
But it is an actual fascinating
environment to work with.
And then, I had a
publisher come to me,
had read something else
I wrote, and he said,
would you like to write a book
about social entrepreneurship,
because we really don't have
one in our category line?
And this is a big publisher.
This is Wiley, actually,
based in San Francisco.
And I made up some--
I'm good at this--
I made up some
answer in my office
because I didn't know
how to answer it,
but I always wanted to
write a book, always.
And it was in the
back of my mind.
And so I said something.
I said, you know, let
me think about it.
I went home, and I
said, wait a second.
The hardest part of publishing
a book is getting a publisher.
And I just got a
publisher and a big one.
So why do I not empower
myself to write a book?
And that's sort of
what a changemaker does
and the essence of it.
You empower yourself
to make change.
And once that happens,
change is inevitable.
So I don't want to just
talk about changemakers.
I want to show you a
three-minute clip about Albina
Ruiz who is a Peruvian
engineer who grew up
in the jungles of the Amazon.
And luckily for us, the Amazon
doesn't have a university.
So she was forced to
move to Lima in order
to pursue her degree.
And she wanted to be an
engineer really badly, really
wanted to be an engineer.
So Albina moved to Lima
and was pretty poor,
so she moved into a really
poor, dangerous area
in the slums of Lima.
And she was so excited
about moving to Lima,
because it's a big city, and
she comes from the jungle,
and this is big time.
And she gets there.
And she is totally disappointed.
Because all she can see
and all she could smell
is garbage, heaps
and piles of garbage
all around the slums of Lima.
Because no one was
picking up the trash.
Now there are reasons for this.
But basically one of
the things that she
was told when she
asked about it was
that the poor don't
mind being dirty.
They don't care.
But in fact, the poor
do mind being dirty,
and nobody likes to be dirty.
And she decided to do
her master's thesis,
her engineering degree,
around figuring out
a system of collecting
garbage in the slums.
I'm making it sound
easy, but it's not.
The slums are usually
the favelas in Brazil,
the slums in any
country, they're normally
out of the central city,
and they're usually
located on hills and narrow
roads, not paved, gutted.
Very hard to get
garbage trucks up there.
Very hard to collect garbage.
What do you do with the garbage?
At that time in Lima,
believe this or not, they
were dumping the
garbage in the rivers,
because that was encouraged
and that was the only place
to dump the garbage.
So she figured this out.
And she started an organization
called Healthy City.
And at the end of
her interview--
and by the way, this is
filmed by me on my Mac,
so it's not professional-- the
videographer said, why don't we
put a little tag in this
that says filmed on location
so people will know I didn't do
it, which was the videographer,
I didn't do this.
But she gave me such
a fabulous answer
about what she has learned
along the way and her journey
with changemakers.
If you indulge me, there's
a three-minute clip
I'd love to play for you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-The big lesson for me is
we never finish to learning.
I learning every day,
not in the academic
only, not in the big meetings.
It's incredible.
I learning every
day in the landfill,
in the streets, when I talk
with the waste pickers,
when I talk with the public
worker, with the mayors
or in the market.
When I met with the
women in the supermarket
and I explained why she don't
need to use the plastic bag,
I explain, please,
you use the basket
or you use the healthy bag.
Because you don't
pollution there,
you don't pollution the world.
And she say, oh my
goodness, I can.
Yeah, but this is
your responsibility,
because we don't expecting
the mayors or the ministers
changing, you changing.
Because if every time we
talk with the children,
with the women, with the men,
and say, you need changing.
You change first and after that
you talking with other changes.
In Ciudad Saludable,
we can use the slogan,
we learning from Ashoka,
everyone can change the world.
This slogan we put in
our strategic plan,
yeah, because it's
very important for us.
We don't need to accumulate
the things, the money.
We need have a good life.
And I am happy with a children's
smile, with the women's smile,
when they have a good job, when
they can improve the house,
when the children go to school.
This is the small
things is so important.
This is very important.
This is millions
of dollars for me,
this smile, this good
house for the poor family.
This is the best salary for me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ:
So here is the thing
that I found that I didn't
see anywhere else-- putting
it all together--
empathy coupled
with a stickiness of the
past experience triggered
by an incident.
So what do I mean by that?
So if you don't know who
the Guardian Angels were,
you would not know who
Nikita Khrushchev was,
who is the premier
of Russia, would you?
OK, Willa, thank you.
I happen to know Willa,
met her at a meeting
before she worked at
Google, so I know her name.
So Willa knows.
Thank you, Willa.
I knew there was a reason
for you to be here.
I had my Khrushchev moment, my
stickiness of past experience.
So when I was a kid, I was
listening to the radio,
washing the dishes one night.
Now, Nikita Khrushchev was
premier when John F. Kennedy
was our president of
the United States.
Because not everybody here
is from the United States.
And there was something called
the Cuban Missile Crisis.
And it was really
heavy duty scary.
And Nikita Khrushchev was
threatening a nuclear war.
And I have to tell you,
it was a scary time.
Some of us remember it,
like me, very scary.
Little kid, young.
And I was washing the dishes,
and I was daydreaming.
And I was going to be
the American girl who
wrote a letter to
Nikita Khrushchev.
And because of my
letter, he was going
to realize that nuclear war
was not going to happen,
and peace was going to
reign over the world.
And that was my dream.
I was a kid.
I was like-- well, I'm
not going to tell you
how old I was-- but this
was, you know, a kid's dream.
I was really empowered.
I went to sleep.
I got up the next morning.
I did absolutely nothing about
this, absolutely nothing.
And I think that has stayed in
my brain for a long, long time.
That is a stickiness
of past experience,
that when the publisher walked
into my office and asked,
do you want to write a book
about social entrepreneurship,
it triggered my
incident and allowed
me to go back to my
past, to be thinking
about what was in front of
me, and to do a future action
that I don't really
think I would have done
without understanding
how sad it made me
not to have done
anything many years ago
around a social situation
that I believed deeply in.
Again, a difference in
a social entrepreneur,
I'd say 90% of the
social entrepreneurs
I interviewed had a
stickiness of past experience
that, when something triggered
it, they couldn't turn away
and they actually turned
their entire life upside down
to figure out how to
solve the problem.
So Isaac, Nigerian,
one of those people
who had a stickiness of past.
And he was a security guard.
I didn't even
mention that before.
So he is a security guard,
college educated by the way,
but a security guard, goes out
of Nigeria to go to college,
comes back to Nigeria and
becomes a security guard
and realizes that the whole
issue around toileting
was very different
in his country.
So as a security guard
of high-end politicians
and wealthy people, he wore
a suit, drove in a suit,
wore a suit, waited
outside the car in a suit.
And he had to relieve
himself in the bushes.
He is, by the way,
six foot seven.
So as he said to me, it
was very upsetting to me
to have to go into the
bushes because there
was no tree or bush
big enough to hide me.
And it's hard.
I mean, if you have
traveled, a lot of you,
to developing countries.
And you know, people just
go wherever they can.
There's not a lot of
running water in Lagos.
In restaurants, they
don't do bathrooms.
And so you go outside to relieve
yourself, and you come back in.
It really bothered him.
And then one day,
he was planning
a wedding for 10,000 people,
which I have come to know
is not unusual for a
rich person in Nigeria.
Everybody is invited from
all over the country.
And he said, oh my
god, what a security
risk this is going to be.
Everybody is going
to go to the bushes
to relieve themselves
during the wedding.
I can't control this.
So he scours Nigeria
for portable toilets,
because he learned that when
he went outside Nigeria.
15, that's all he can find, 15.
This is a wedding
for 10,000 people.
So it was right
then and there he
decided he was going to
bring the portable toilet
industry to Nigeria.
But he didn't do it
in a normal fashion,
because then he wouldn't have
been a social entrepreneur.
So he hires at-risk
youth and homeless
men to build the toilets.
And he franchises
them to single,
head of household women.
Stickiness point, his
mother was a single,
head of household woman.
So this whole project that
he came up with in his mind
was all about giving single,
head of household women
the ability to make a living.
Eventually, it's 60/40 split,
60 to the women, 40 to Isaac.
And he takes off 10% of every
payment on the franchise.
And when he has enough
money, the woman
owns the actual toilet.
And if he inculcates toileting
into the culture of Nigeria,
this will be a
sustainable income
source for years and
years and years to come.
So that's what I
mean by triggering
and what I call
a virtuous cycle.
From inception,
all the way around,
every single stage
of the innovation
benefits somebody's life in
a socially sustainable way.
So very quickly, there are
five sections to the book.
And every single
entrepreneur I've ever met,
social entrepreneur,
falls into one
of these categories of work.
And very quickly,
restructuring industry norms.
Ursula Sladek, a German
woman-- I got really,
really riled at the last time I
said she was just a housewife,
and people said, how could
you do that-- labels herself
as just a housewife,
50 years old.
When Chernobyl, the nuclear
power plant in Russia,
exploded many years
ago, the radiation
wafted all through
Europe, and everybody
was told to stay indoors
for quite a while.
And children shouldn't play.
Because it did land on grass and
forests and trees, and people
were really worried about how
this affected their children.
Well, at 50 years old, she's
watching the kids play outside.
And she said, I just can't
go through this again.
And I am going to work towards
the end of nuclear power,
anything nuclear
power, in Germany.
And by God, she started to
learn how to use a computer.
She started an
organization which
is now the largest
supplier of solar, wind,
and water energy in Germany.
She exports power to
other European countries.
The people in her town-- she
comes from the Black Forest--
are all people who now
have bought into it.
They're shareholders.
They're owners of the company.
They all have generators.
The excess energy they
create gets fed back
into the large scheme of things.
And she is now-- and
the news reports all
say it-- the primary
influence for Angela Merkel,
saying that by
2020, Germany will
be nondependent
on nuclear power.
So that's making an
entire industry change.
That is restructuring
an entire industry.
Mary Gordon-- and I
think you're going
to love this one-- Mary was
an educator who was really
tired of seeing kids
bullied in school.
Now you know this is a huge
problem, not only in the United
States but in a lot of places.
And she didn't know
what to do about it.
So she came up with
an amazing project.
And basically it's around
making emotional literacy
a part of school curriculum.
And what Mary does,
which is a blow away,
is she has a nine-month
program where
she brings a small child
and the mother into class.
And through the
child, the kids start
understanding the
behavior of a child.
So they thought, why
does the baby cry?
What do you think the baby's
feeling when it smiles?
What do you think
the baby wants?
And the kids start
talking about the feelings
of the baby, a very
neutral, safe space.
And all of a sudden, it opens
up the whole discussion around,
and so how do you think
your neighbor feels
when you steal his hat?
How do you think Sarah feels
when you pull her hair?
And even the most sort of tough
kids, when they hold the baby,
they soften.
And there's a whole another
part of them that comes out.
And this is what she uses in
her emotional literacy class
to get kids to understand
the effects of bullying
and aggression.
And by the way, this
has spread like wildfire
throughout schools in not
only the United States
but in quite a few
countries around the world.
And very quickly, advancing
full citizenship, which
is a lot about taking
people who are differently
abled-- and notice, I am
not using the word disabled,
I am using the word differently
abled-- because everybody's
got a skill, and
everybody's got something
that they can do that makes
them special and unique.
So Thorkil Sonne,
Danish, had a son,
at three diagnosed with autism.
And he said, what
will happen to my son
when my wife and I
are no longer here?
How will he take
care of himself?
How will he earn a living?
He was, very close to your
heart, a software engineer.
And he realized that the
skills of an autistic child
are focus, persistence,
and actually,
in a lot of ways, patience.
So he said, why can't I
trained people with autism
to be software checkers, right?
It takes a lot of focus.
It takes a lot of persistence.
So he set up a program.
And he uses LEGO, by the way,
to train them on how things work
and patience and
frustration and all of that.
And IBM's probably one
of his biggest clients.
And they set up a little bit
different sort of scenario.
Because what he said to
me is, people with autism
don't like open space.
That's very threatening to them.
So the client makes
some adjustments.
He trains the
people with autism.
And they go to work as
consultants, have a job.
And one of the IBM
managers has actually
said that they actually
make better employees.
They show up on time.
They're always there.
They never take breaks.
They just keep on working.
And they're wonderful employees.
So he has developed an
employment agency for people
with autism.
And it's pretty awesome.
And he just opened his
first non-Danish office,
and it's in Delaware.
So he's now come into
the United States.
And the last one is using market
forces for social business.
That's Albina.
And by the way, as
an engineer, this
is the three-legged
trash pickup that
goes up the curvy, small,
narrow hills to the slums
and picks up the trash.
It's a social enterprise.
It's a business.
It's fee for service.
And now the
municipalities pay her
to recycle and pick up trash.
So she creates millions of
jobs, helps the environment,
helps the sanitation and health
of people who no longer have
to be trash pickers with their
kids, cleans up the smells,
cleans up the bugs.
It's an amazing
enterprise, and it
uses market forces to
change social business.
And the last one on
this is Greg Van Kirk.
And he takes a market which
is known as consignment.
Everybody here knows
what consignment is.
You know, people sell
things on consignment.
You give them something,
and they sell it.
Well, the way it goes
in the developing world
is that people buy a product,
and they go out and sell it.
But what happens if they can't
afford to buy the first tranche
product, right?
Nothing.
They can't do it.
So he has an organization that
does micro reverse microcredit,
which means he buys the
first tranche product, which
are reading glasses, things
that are helpful, solar lights,
and he sends people--
changemakers-- up
to the rural communities--
started in Guatemala,
now it's all over Latin
America-- and they sell this.
And when they make the
money on the products,
they take a little
bit of amount.
They pay him back-- and
then they have enough money
to buy another tranche--
until they pay him back
for the first tranche products.
So by taking an industry
norm and twisting
it to make it
innovative and to make
it implementable in
the developing world,
he creates a whole new market
based on a reverse model.
So last one, and only
because he's local,
he's in the East
Bay, it's Paul Rice.
Now, has anybody here
heard of fair trade?
I know.
It's not Nikita
Khrushchev, guys.
You're in California.
Everybody has heard
of fair trade.
Paul is the person who brought
fair trade to the United States
from Nicaragua,
where he was working
with the Nicaraguan farmers.
So of interest is
his stickiness,
what I found out at the
end of the interview, was
he grew up on a
farm in the Midwest,
and his mother was a
single, head of household.
And so he went, after
college, to work,
when there was a
rebellion in Nicaragua,
and he was all liberal and
was going to help the farmers
and help the people
of Nicaragua,
and he ended up helping the
Nicaraguan coffee farmers.
And he realized how to bring
that model to Nicaragua
and then how to bring
it to the United States.
So every time you walk into
Whole Foods or Trader Joe's
and you see fair trade.
And even lately-- and
we helped him with this
a few years ago with
Starbucks-- he bucked Starbucks.
And he went
head-to-head with why
they weren't serving
fair trade coffee.
And to this day, what do you
see when you go to Starbucks?
You see fair trade coffee now.
So these are the kind of people
that inspire me every day.
And what does the
future look like
of social entrepreneurship?
Well, it's apparent that for
social disruption to continue,
social entrepreneurs need to
be able to attract and retain
changemakers, right?
And we have to have a whole
different social architecture
in our minds that work towards
this vision of in everyone
a changemaker world.
We really have to take a
lot of the stuff that's
happening at Google
and turn it outwards
and help other corporations.
And this isn't only individuals.
There are changemaker
corporations, as well.
So right now I'm
working with one
that is giving me
intense joy, because they
are looking at
every single system.
And they are a big player
in the pharmaceutical field.
They are looking at every
single internal system
and seeing how they could
dismantle it and rebuild
it to create employees who
think in innovative ways
and are creative enough.
And their goal-- a couple
of them, one of which is I'm
working with them in Africa,
as well-- but one of them
is that this is going to be
their key to staying ahead
of the competition, right?
So they are what we call
changemaker corporations.
And I want to leave
you with a statement.
Remember, I mentioned somebody
was a truck driver turned
social entrepreneur?
Well, he's French,
and he works in Calais
on the northern part of France.
And I spent a day with him.
And at the end of
the interview, he
said to me that really
made my heart beat faster.
And I want to share it with you.
And he said to me, when we
invest in human behavior,
in human value, in human
capacity, there are no taxes.
We invest.
We don't have to pay a tax.
And we are always richer
no matter what happens.
He said, when you
speak from your soul,
it's a universal language
that everyone can understand
and everybody could commit to.
So my wish for today is that
when you read "Rippling"
and you close the
book, you're inspired
the way I am speaking
to Francois and to all
of the other social
entrepreneurs.
And this is the joy that I
get from working at Ashoka.
Because I get surrounded
by these people every day.
And they inspire me.
So I hope you'll be
inspired, as well.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So what's the
correlation with profitability?
You know, we have an
economy with basically very
profit-driven companies.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Right.
AUDIENCE: And I
think that the future
is where profit can be
aligned with social.
And I'm just wondering,
for all the examples
that you gave, how competitive
are these solutions,
compared with other solutions
in the market that are really
focused on trying to make money
and to reduce costs, et cetera?
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ:
They're not going
to be competitive in
the respect of cornering
the market for a
certain service.
But I have to tell you,
profit is not a dirty word
here at all.
And there is correlation.
Because what you
try to do is make
your innovation and your
organization sustainable.
And part of the thing we always
know is that depending on donor
dollars isn't always the wisest
way to go, because donors
have trends that they fund.
So Isaac, Albina, Greg,
they're all social enterprises.
And they have a fee for service.
And they keep themselves
sustainable that way.
But they'll never
be billionaires.
And they won't have
the shareholders.
And they're not working to
make money for shareholders.
They're really
working to make money
for ordinary people, actually
poor people for the most part.
So there's a
correlation for sure.
But the correlation
is always going
to be a lot lower on
the profit than it
will be for a dot-com or a
profit-making organization.
There's no doubt about that.
You don't go into
this to be rich.
You go into this for
emotional fulfillment.
AUDIENCE: My question, you
mentioned that there was, like,
a pattern between all of
the people you interviewed,
about a stickiness point.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Right.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious if
you saw any patterns as sort
of like what pushed them
over the edge to take action?
Because I think probably a
lot of people in the room
share a similar empathy
and desire to do something.
But what's that moment where
you really go out and do it?
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: You know,
I wish I could quantify that.
And I wish I had a
formula to tell you that.
But what I can say is how strong
is the triggering incident,
and where our their minds?
And so Greg Van Kirk
was a corporate banker,
a really successful
corporate banker.
And you know what he did?
He quit, and he went
to the Peace Corps.
And that's kind of his pathway.
And that's how he
understood what
was needed in the rural
communities in Guatemala.
I can't quantify that.
But I can say if the stickiness
is as strong as the triggering
incident, it flips a switch.
And if I knew what
that switch was,
we'd be having a
very different talk.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell
more about what are some
of the efforts
that you have right
now to expand the
reach of Ashoka?
I mean, do you need more money?
I mean, how is the funding?
Because you do pay the stipends
to all of the entrepreneurs.
So I was just wondering if
money is the question that
is going to help you reach
more of those entrepreneurs,
or what are some
of the alternatives
that you're working with?
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ:
Well, obviously,
I cannot say no to money.
But that's obvious.
In fact, Google has been
generous in some ways.
It's very funny, a
lot of people that
really have an
affinity for Ashoka
are technology entrepreneurs.
But that's part of it.
But it's something like
Radhika is doing now.
She has gotten totally
immersed in the Ashoka culture
and got excited about it.
And she said, can I start a
chapter in Silicon Valley?
And part of that is to
get people understanding
the changemaker
mentality set-- you know,
I have to be honest--
as well as funding.
So yes, every use
social entrepreneur
takes a certain
amount of funding.
And it's funny.
We're just opening
an office in Greece.
In fact, as we speak, our
staff person is moving there.
And we only open an office when
we have three years of funding
in the bank, because we fund
three years of stipends.
And we just got it.
And Greece, of course, now
is very interesting to us,
what's going on
economically there.
It's a hot bed to
look for innovations
that impact the economy
in a social way.
So am I leaving
anything out, Radhika,
that you'd like to say on this?
RADHIKA SHAH: Well,
that's perfect.
But we are also looking at
people actively engaging
with social entrepreneurs.
So many of us here,
including myself,
we like to also be engaged and
be more active for the causes.
And so even if you're in
that category, come chat.
And we are looking at the
ways of them getting deeply
with Ashoka Fellows
doing amazing stuff based
on whichever cause
you care about,
with also possibly funding and
also actively engaging them.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Yeah, so
it's not only funding for us.
It's like getting
involved, understanding
what a social entrepreneur does.
I cannot tell you how exciting
it is when we elect somebody
as an Ashoka Fellow.
And you know what they say?
Oh my god, I'm not crazy.
Everybody thinks I'm crazy.
Like Albina, they thought she
was crazy, first in a class.
Why was she dealing
with garbage?
Why was she caring
about these poor people?
Oh, I'm not crazy.
There is a field called
social entrepreneurs.
We're a social entrepreneur, and
you have given us credibility.
That's sort of what we're
trying to do, as well.
AUDIENCE: Do you go after
funding from governments,
local governments, or,
like, philanthropists?
Because I just wanted
to understand more.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ:
Great question.
We take no money from
the government, none.
It's one of the reasons I
was attracted to Ashoka.
Shh, don't say anything.
And we also don't take any money
from quasi-governmental banks,
no World Bank money,
no IDB money, nothing.
So we are solely funded by
mostly private individuals
and corporations
and foundations.
Yep.
So we don't have many
strings attached.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Apart from
finding funding,
as you talked about
being a disrupter,
there is an intense interest.
So obviously in the product
space, we have businesses.
And a lot of these
stories you tell us,
the government, things
with corruption, the Mafia,
you know, things that could even
provide a physical or financial
risk to a lot of the
people, and organizations
are associated
with those people.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Probably.
AUDIENCE: So how do
you deal with that
from both helping
them and providing
political and business
leverage to cover?
And how do you
protect Ashoka's brand
from maybe some of the
attacks you might get?
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Yeah,
that's a fabulous question.
I have to say, when we open
a new office in a place,
we look very much at
the civil society there.
So we've been encouraged
in China and Russia.
And it's too much risk for us.
And there are certain
countries in Africa
we can't go to either.
We have a Belgian funder who
wants us to go into the Congo.
And we just won't do it yet.
It's too unsafe.
However, the countries
we're in, it happens.
We have a security
program, and it's funded.
And we actually take
Fellows and their families
and fly them out.
It's sort of like a
new life kind of thing.
And we recently had
to do that in Nigeria.
Just a few months ago, one
of our Fellows in Pakistan
was killed.
Because as a disrupter,
when you disrupt government
or the system, the
culture, you're a target.
So we work really
carefully with our offices.
When there's a threat, and
we think there's a threat,
we have a fund that gets
Fellows and their families out
of the country.
And they don't return
until it's safe.
It's a very, very tough problem.
We worry about it.
I'm doing a workshop in Africa,
in Nairobi, in February.
And a whole day is committed.
It's a security workshop
for the African Fellows.
So what do you do?
How do you do it?
And what we do is we
have all the Fellows
act as support to each other.
So we actually have
buddies they call
if they think
they're threatened.
And it's almost like a chain,
sort of like an electric wire,
and they rally around the
Fellow and we figure out
what to do as a group.
But it is a tough problem,
because when you disrupt,
you're a target.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
wondering if we
can do something else to
empower social entrepreneurs
with new technologies or
disruptive technologies,
more or less use of the internet
cloud and things like that?
I think this can be of
interest to Googlers like me.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: No, no,
no, you're absolutely right.
You know, it's funny.
I just did a webinar.
And we live streamed
it from a conference.
And we were trying to live
stream three people from Africa
in.
Two out of the three had
no connectivity that day.
And we had rehearsed.
And we did a dry
run the day before.
And on that day,
no connectivity.
So part of it is, yes,
that would be great.
And part of it is no,
because the infrastructure
in a lot of places isn't
even close to there.
But absolutely willing
to listen to any ideas.
Because our Fellows
eat up the technology.
And if we can train them
to be more efficient,
that's part of the issue
that's really helpful.
So if you can think of
anything, willing to listen.
We love it.
I was chatting
with Charlie who is
doing a big project
in Africa, as well.
And he was talking
about wireless.
And I said to him,
let's talk afterward.
You never know where there's a
sweet spot between technology
and social
entrepreneurship in Africa.
So yes, thank you.
CHARLIE HARDING: Thank you
so much, Bev, for your talk.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Thank you.
This is great.
Thanks, everybody.
CHARLIE HARDING: And books
are available outside.
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
BEVERLY SCHWARTZ: Great.
Thank you.